[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hi friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
she has one of the most pure and love
voices of the 20th century
several of the songs that she sang
appeared on the american film
institute's list of top 100 songs of all
time
yet virtually nobody knows her name why
because she was a ghost singer marnie
nixon was perhaps not as beautiful as
some movie stars
but she was blessed with a golden voice
when hollywood studios wanted to ensure
their actresses sang flawlessly
they would frequently dub in the voice
of this talented american soprano
marty nixon did all of the singing for
deborah kerr
in the king and i natalie wood in west
side story
and audrey hepburn in my fair lady all
which won multiple academy awards
she also sang for many other hollywood
greats like marilyn monroe sophia lauren
janet lee yet for all of the blockbuster
songs that she made famous
she was paid very little and almost
never received any credit
in fact marnie was threatened that if
she ever divulged
she was the real voice behind these
legendary musicals
she would be forever blackballed from
working in hollywood
eventually as it always does the truth
got out
and marnie was recognized as the golden
voice ghost singer
for all of these hollywood greats did
you know the bible talks about a special
group in heaven
that sings a song nobody else can sing
stay with his friends we're going to
learn more on this edition
of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome listening friends the bible
answers live we're so glad that you've
tuned in to this
live international inc interactive bible
study
and you can tell from the name of the
broadcast this is
a live bible study if you have bible
questions we'd encourage
you to give us a call the number is 800
god says that's 800-463-7297
we're also streaming on facebook if you
want to see what's happening here in the
studio
you can simply go to the amazing facts
facebook page
or the doug batchelor facebook page and
you will see
yours truly along with our co-host and i
am doug batchelor
my name is john ross good evening
friends and pass today as we always do
let's start with prayer
dear father we thank you that we can
take time to open up your word and study
together
and we do ask that you would be with us
we pray that you'd be with those who are
listening
we know some might be in their car or at
home wherever they might be lord
and may we come to a clear understanding
of the powerful word of god so we ask
you a blessing on this program in jesus
name
amen amen well pastor you think about
how
in today's world how important name
recognition is
and um everyone's pursuing fame or
fortune and especially in in the world
of entertainment
and yet the amazing fact of a woman that
was quite content to use her gifts
to sing and yet she was not able to uh
boast
of her songs or really tell a whole lot
of people what she did and yet
her voice was used for some very famous
uh actors and movies just amazing it is
it's an incredible story
and it's sad in a way because probably
millions of dollars i'm not exaggerating
of royalties have come in for those
songs
and she was paid a few hundred dollars
for when she sang and then had to sign a
contract that she was basically
releasing any credit for doing so
and yet you know whenever you hear any
of those classic songs it's
almost always marnie nixon in the king
and i
west side story my fair lady and many
many others
she did finally get to do a cameo
appearance where she sang with her own
voice
in the sound of music and i think she
was one of the nuns
but uh yeah she had a beautiful voice
that
got a lot of praise and no one really
knew who was behind it
but you know it makes me think of a
passage in the bible
about a special group that gets to sing
a song and they're the only ones
if you've got your bibles you can go to
revelation chapter 14 and we are talking
about the 144 thousand
and then i looked and behold a lamb
sitting on mount zion and with him
144 000 having his father's name written
on their foreheads
and i heard a voice out of heaven like
the voice of many waters and the voice
of a loud thunder
and i heard the sound of harpists
playing their harps
and they sang as it was a new song
before the throne
and before the four living creatures and
the elders and no one could learn that
song
except for the hundred and forty four
thousand
who were redeemed from the earth what do
you think that song is pastor ross
well we know it's something to do with
the song of moses and the lamb it's the
song of deliverance
i think it's one of those songs that the
redeemed the hundred and forty four
thousand will be able to sing without
having to
memorize the words they will be inspired
to share their experience
amen that's what you call a mass choir
144 000 singing at one time
that's right that'll be something now
some people might have
some questions about who are the 144 000
and
we have a gift book for anyone who wants
to have the free study on that subject
we have a book entitled who will sing
the song understanding 144 000 of course
we mentioned 144 000 we find it twice in
revelation both in revelation 7 and also
in revelation 14.
we'll be happy to send this book to
anyone who would call and ask all you'll
have to do is call our
resource phone line that's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four
seven and as for the book who will sing
the song understanding the hundred and
forty four thousand
i'll be happy to get in the mail and
send it to you if you're outside of
north america
you can go to the amazing facts website
just amazingfacts.com
we do have a free library and you can
type in 144 000
i'm sure you'll have the book pop up and
you'll be able to read that online
all right pasta deck we're ready for our
first caller let's see we have somebody
calling from sydney australia
fadi welcome to the program
thank you thank you and your question
uh revelation uh uh
six and five all right let me read that
for those that are listening we always
know there's a lot of our listeners who
are
pre-preoccupied driving a vehicle or
cooking a dinner
when he opened the third seal i heard
the third living creature say
come and see and so i looked and behold
a black horse and he who sat on it
had a pair of scales in his hand you
wanted to know who is the writer on the
black horse
yes who is the writer and what's it mean
and
is it the the mark of the beast sunday
well this writer i don't think has
anything specifically to do with
the mark of the beast uh you have in
revelation you've got
a group of sevens that outline different
phases of church history keep in mind
when john has the vision of revelation
at the very beginning he says
these things that are about to come to
pass so the visions he was having they
were going to begin to come to pass
right about his time you have seven
churches that gives the religious
history of the church from the first
coming to the second coming
then you have seven seals which gives
sort of a political history
of the church from the first coming to
the second coming then you have the
seven
trumpets that give more of a military
history
of some of the religious battles between
the first coming and the second coming
the black rider on the black horse
is represented by one of the first
four seals and you got the four horsemen
of the apocalypse
pastor ross maybe you want to jump in
here yeah maybe just add a little more
if you look at these seals there
that i've mentioned they represent seven
time periods
uh pretty much from the time of the
apostles all the way through to our time
and when you look at the third seal
where it's talking about this
rider on a black horse it represents a
time period during the middle ages where
you find the word of god was in scarce
supply there were a number of pagan
practices and teachings that were coming
into the church
at the time and in essence the truth was
under severe strain and that's the black
hole symbolizes a decline or a lack of
purity white represents purity and
truth you have the black holes
representing error and yet it talks
about
a price it says a court of wheat for
daenerys three quarts of barley for
daenerys
these prices were about eight times
eight to twelve times
higher than the normal prices for grain
at the time
a wheat you make bread it symbolizes the
word of god so the word of god was in
scarce supply
although it was still you could still
find it you had groups like the
waldenses who
were in the mountains of northern italy
who were able to trance they still
translated the word of god
they believed the teachings the gospel
found in the scriptures
but by and large throughout europe there
was a darkness that's what's called the
dark ages a lack of biblical truth and
understanding
yeah a dearth of truth and even the last
part of that verse it says
and hurt not the oil and the wine two
other symbols for the blood of the
covenant and the holy spirit
so god was still working but uh that
rider on the black horse there was a lot
of
error and darkness that came into the
treatment church during that time
thank you fady for your question from
australia we've got uh yosef listening
from
dallas texas yosef welcome to the
program
hi thank you pastors um yeah so my my
question is regarding leviticus 11 where
it says that there's clean and unclean
food and then i was wondering if you
guys could help rectify the differences
that i'm finding
in genesis 9 3 and colossians 2 16
about food and what i should eat or
drink
okay well you've asked the big question
first of all on leviticus
chapter 11 was there a specific verse in
that chapter you're wondering about
that no it's just a general idea about
the clean
and the unclean for consumption okay
very good
um you know in the very beginning god's
plan for man
was a vegetarian diet you know that was
for everybody it wasn't whether you're a
jew or a muslim or anything
uh god had adam and eve he said you know
i've given you the trees of the field
and the original diet for man and woman
was fruits grains and nuts
after sin he said you can no longer eat
from the tree of life and then god
added vegetables to the diet
it wasn't until after the flood that
meat started
to be eaten more commonly and that was
in association with
a sacrifice so there are only clean
animals that could be sacrificed so when
noah went on the ark
they already knew the difference between
clean and unclean because
he took the clean animals by seven and
the unclean were taken two by two
so man was never to eat the unclean
animals
um and then you know when it talks about
in uh
earlier in genesis or with noah god
tells him not to eat
he's allowed to eat the meat but he says
he was not to eat the blood
thereof but that was assuming they were
clean animals
and then i think the other verse that
you're referring to is colossians
chapter 2 verse 16
which says let no man judge you in food
or in drink or regards a festival a new
moon or a sabbath
and yeah pastor the paul is writing to
the believers in current he's not
talking about clean and unclean foods
he's rather talking about food that have
been
offered to an idol in the marketplace
and certain foods that even at the time
there were those who are
saying you could need certain things on
certain days it had nothing to do with
clean unclean foods
that principle was always there you
can't take that the verse where paul
says let no man judge you regarding food
or drink because
you know theoretically your kid could be
getting ready for school in the morning
and eating a hot fudge sundae for
breakfast and you say you can't eat that
and they could quote you colossians and
say
mom dad you're not to judge me regarding
food or drinking i mean so obviously god
wants us to be responsible about what we
eat and drink and this was not a carte
blanc for people to
eat unclean food it was talking about
stuff offered idols and we have a lesson
on that
we do it's called god's free health plan
that's one of our amazing facts study
guides
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line again just ask for the study guide
it's called god's free health plan as
mentioned to the previous caller it's
also available for you to read
at the amazing facts website thanks for
your call
we've got derek listening in minnesota
derek welcome to the program
well hi pastor ross hi pastor doug
i have a quick um well a praise i guess
i could say um i remember you told a
sermon where
you said like the table of showbread the
incense and then
um the witness the candlestick you know
those are the three disciplines of a
christian
and i just started taking that to heart
and then i put in like daniel where he
prayed three times a day
so i combined that and i've had a huge
you know revival in my life like before
i was really
warm but yeah like doing that three
times a day
you know even witnessing sending out a
track you know people can mail something
out to anybody you know it's google
earth you can find an address somewhere
and just
mail something out you know it's just
it's just really helped me a lot and
that's neat yeah praise for that my
question is
about the false messiah i'm kind of
confused on the timeline
from what i've heard is like he gets a
shot like a three and a half year shot
like
jesus did so i'm assuming that's before
that
the millennium happens or the
thousand-year sabbath
so is he going to be hanging out with
the you know
people of earth for three and a half
years and then the very end they make
the
like a law against god's um a man-made
law against god's law
and then like that's kind of the
abomination of desolation i'm just a
little confused on the timeline like
how you think it'll play out or the
bible says it'll play out
right you know that's a common belief i
i have trouble finding that in the bible
uh derek because
i think what happens in pastor ross
might correct me i think people take
the prophecies in daniel where it talks
about
the three and a half and that first
three and a half is talking about a time
where the messiah is going to preach
three and a half years
then he's cut off uh jesus dies on the
cross
and you know the the roman power of
course executed him
and um then for another three and a half
years he preaches through
the apostles those that hurt him and
then they take that and they put that
down at the end of time and they sort of
create
a uh the negative of that where the
devil gets three and a half years
we don't know it could be three and a
half but i don't know a prophecy or a
scripture that says that
specifically some take daniel 12
and there's another 1260 in daniel
chapter 12.
1260 by the way it's three and a half
years 1260
jewish days had 42 months or 360 days in
the year
and they put that at the end of time but
i don't think daniel 12 is talking about
that
so yeah you know actually i would say
probably not if you're talking about
this the devil
who comes impersonating the second
coming of christ he probably won't be on
the earth for three and a half
years and and the reason i say that is
revelation chapter 18 verse 8
speaks about plagues coming upon babylon
this
uh this power this religious political
power and it says a plague shall come in
one day
death morning and famine now we know
that one biblical day
is equal to a symbolic day is equal to
one literal year
so it appears that after probation
closes you have about a year
of plagues that come upon the earth or
connected with the plague
is at some point a uh impersonation of
the second coming of christ
the devil claims to be christ and
galvanizes
the nations of the world to actually
pass a death decree according to
revelation chapter 13.
that those who refuse to go along with
these manmade laws that contradict the
bible
they're going to be put to death so i
don't know whether it's going to i don't
believe that time will
continue for three and a half years it
seems to be a shorter period of time
right near the end yeah you know and
when the the plagues came on the
egyptians
you start reading that in context and
that all happened in a matter of months
it wasn't years
that those 10 plagues came so that would
make sense
i hope that helps a little bit uh derek
and we appreciate your call
and your kind comment as well the next
quality we have is ruth listening in
texas ruth welcome to the program hi
hi how are you good
and your question tonight my question
is since the bible says we have to
forgive everyone
do we have to forgive the devil okay
good question
um you know i don't think when jesus
says
he wants us to love and forgive our
neighbor that he's including the devil
someone once asked who is my neighbor
jesus tells an illustration of someone
who is in need and speaking of another
human
the forgiving the devil would almost
empower and encourage him to continue
hurting more people
so and the other thing is jesus said if
your brother comes to you
and he asks for forgiveness you should
forgive him the devil's not asking for
forgiveness
he is unrepentant he is proud he is
stubborn and so no
you're not supposed to forgive the devil
and and jesus he's not asking for it and
jesus
is not forgiving the devil because he's
kind of committed the unpardonable sin
past the point of no return he had
opportunity to be forgiven probably
before he got to that point and
he just pushed god's mercy beyond its
limit it reminds me of a
dvd set that we have it's called um
cosmic conflict ruth
you might have seen this but if not i
think it's available online
and it talks about the fall of lucifer
up in heaven and his rebellion and uh
how things ended up the way they are and
i think you'd find that informative
again the uh the documentary produced by
amazing fact facts is called cosmic
conflict
and they can she can go to youtube and
just watch it it's free yeah we've got
noah listening in uh
illinois noah welcome to the program hi
dog hi
gene and yes you can watch cosmic
hello yeah you're on
yes you can watch cosmic conflict on
youtube
that's why i watch it thank you and your
question tonight
my question is is there a chance that
daniel and
esther knew each other are new of each
other
probably not because esther comes along
during the time
of ahaziwaris he was a persian king that
lived after
cyrus the bible tells us in daniel
chapter one that daniel
survived until the first reign i think
the first year of
uh cyrus and uh
you know cyrus reigned for many years so
daniel had probably died several years
before
esther came on the scene which was one
or two kings after
or three after uh he has he wears
you know seriously i'm looking at the
timeline that we have it's called
um timelinebiblehistory.com yeah
and it's produced by amazing facts and
i'm actually looking at it right here
it's got
uh s that's got daniel it gives you a
rough estimate of the time
it looks like it was about 60 70 years
between the death of daniel
yeah to esther becoming the queen so uh
even if he was very old and she started
very young it's not likely their lives
overlapping right
it was too much good question yeah they
i'll tell you esther certainly knew
about daniel you can be sure of that
thanks for your call now we've got let's
see mike is listening in st louis
missouri mike welcome to the program
hi how are you guys doing oh we're
enjoying what we do
well that's good well here i i'll read
this real quick it's luke chapter 21
verse 24.
it says jerusalem will be downtrodden by
the gentiles
until the time of the gentiles is
fulfilled
and here's my question does the six
day war in 1967
when the israelis captured all of
jerusalem
prove that the time of the gentiles is
fulfilled
all right you know i won't answer that
with a yes or no because
that may have been a part i think this
is a dual prophecy actually what jesus
is talking about
jerusalem will be trampled by the
gentiles until the time of the gentiles
is fulfilled
uh jerusalem when it talks about the new
jerusalem in revelation it's talking
about god's people his church his bride
we go to the wedding wedding supper of
the lamb in the new jerusalem and so
god's people had been trampled by the
enemy so that's one
part of it but i said it's a dual
prophecy i also do think
that you cannot avoid the incredible
fact of history that the jewish nation
has been dispossessed from their land
three times since the time of abraham
they're stuck in egypt after you know
jacob came out
then they were captured and taken to
babylon then they were dispersed by the
romans
and even after 3 500 years
they have now regained that land which
really was 1947 that
pastor ross and i were talking about the
six day award just before the broadcast
tonight he just finished a book on the
subject
and but that was 67 is that right
yeah right around yeah it was in the 60s
anyway there were several walls but the
six they
sort of took jerusalem and yeah so 1948
they really got their independence as a
nation so some people date
the time of the gentiles being fulfilled
as that
others think it was more they got so
much more territory after the six day
war it was a six-day war
but i you know i think that sort of is
uh it's a dual prophecy
but no one can deny that god did
something marvelous in giving the jews
their independence
and again in spite of the incredible
odds
that they are up against surrounded by
in many cases hostile nations
you know i think pastor you did an
amazing facts once on the jewish nation
on how you have them uh driven from
their homeland
uh multiple times and yet coming back
and possessing jerusalem their homeland
being dispersed into all of these
different countries and yet still
keeping their own distinct
language their own distinct customs
so it's a rather remarkable group of
people that that god is
sort of guided yeah we talk about that
in our we have a dvd
called kingdoms in time and matter of
fact we just heard this last week
kingdoms and time
i think it won first place at the nrb
new films
so we're very happy for that but uh it's
you can't watch that on youtube yet but
if you go to the amazing facts
website and you look up kingdoms in time
you'll see where we talk about the
history of israel
in that dvd documentary thank you very
much
thanks mike we got uh let's see gail
he's listening in
sustainable canada gail welcome to the
program
hi pastors hi you'll need to turn your
radio off
uh or we'll get feedback how can we help
you tonight
hi how how is houston am i
are you getting the feedback nope sounds
good now
okay my question is since we are
um we have read in the bible that
we need to observe the sabbath from
sundown
to sundown and
for here for us here living in up north
and during summers there are times that
the sun stays up so long
and sometimes we only have two hours of
time
or three hours nights and so how are we
going to observe the sabbath are we
still going to observe the sabbath
up until 10 pm and then
yeah that's a good question and you know
i was in uh
i was in uh alaska uh my whole my wife
and i went
on a cruise to alaska and then i went to
a men's meeting i've been up to the
men's meeting twice now
and you know in the summer time the sun
just didn't even go down that i mean it
never got dark
and you think well the sun technically
did go down but the sky still stayed
illuminated
but you know it was still 24 hours
between when the sun
kind of did go down and came back up
again friends i know
that are keeping the sabbath you know up
in the northern regions or
hypothetically way down in chile in the
or the arctic or somewhere
they usually just pick a spot on the
clock and then i have someone that will
say well how do you keep the sabbath on
the international space
station and you know i say well i
suppose you pick a country
then you say that's my country i'm going
by their time you know when a person
wants to keep the sabbath
they'll find a way to do it and by the
way whether you think the sabbath is
on saturday or sunday christians through
history and jews
have all had the same challenges about
you know what do you do
when you're in the northern extremities
and and
uh yeah you just plot out that 24 hours
on the seventh day
and keep it holy so hope that helps a
little bit
and i know up there in saskatchewan it
uh weapon the north it probably gets
dark very early in the winter and have
long days in the summer
thank you gail for your call tonight
we've got faith listening from texas
faith we've got about a minute uh what's
your question
faith in texas she may be muted
faith are you there if you are we can
yeah um can i i'm going to read
52 1. it says truly my soul waited upon
god from him cometh my salvation when it
says my soul what does it mean
because i've heard your video shorts and
it says we are a soul
oh okay when he says when king david
says my soul waits upon god
he's talking about in his heart his life
the word soul
is uh it's kind of used sometimes in a
fluid manner in the bible and sometimes
the bible says body soul and spirit
sometimes it'll say all the souls in the
sea died and it's talking about fish too
so i made everything alive but you just
look at the context when david says you
know
my soul longs after god
he probably meant it very much the way
we would mean it right now saying it
means from your heart your character
your essence of who you are good
question thank you so much
for that uh faith and uh friends don't
go away by the way lines are open we're
coming back in just a minute or two
i'm going to take a brief break got a
question 800 god says that's 800 463
and coming back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature
and much more call us at af bookstore to
learn more about it
at 1-800-530
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at af afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you
change to see the future
you must understand the past alexander
the great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy 150 years in
advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor doug batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies
that have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time
get your copy today available now on dvd
blu-ray or usb for more information
visit
kingdomsandtime.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7200
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
[Music]
we are back friends and if you'd like to
call in with a bible question this is
bible answers live if you tuned in along
the way a live
international interactive bible study
and the number
is 800-463-7297 with your questions
we are also streaming the program if you
want to see what's going on here in the
studio
that's soon going to be on the af tv
channel and we're just
finishing some of the decorating and the
technical things here in the studio and
you'll be able to not only listen
but watch af tv on our amazing facts
uh bible answers live on af tv
and but right now we're streaming on
facebook that's the amazing facts
facebook page
and the doug batchelor facebook page and
i am doug batchelor
my name is john ross and we have charles
from florida that's listening so we're
going to go to charles charles in
newport florida charles welcome to the
program
hey how's it going guys yeah uh
newport richie's uh having that bipolar
weather right now
so we could make up his mind it's going
to be hot or cold
my question is i mean in our things
we don't wear jewelry okay we don't wear
any jewelry at all
but here's here's what i'm having a
problem with um
i actually sell jewelry for a living i i
i'm actually consulting with pop rock
accessories
you know what by the jewelry from their
factory that i sell online
so my question is this
am i doing something bad i mean is god
gonna look
down on me because the fact i'm selling
jewelry to people
and they're like ooh and everything that
might am i
doing something wrong by contributing to
it or i mean because this is my
income yeah well you know
um first of all i always have to be
careful to
make sure and remind people that we are
not the holy spirit
there are scriptures that tell us that
you know god does not look upon
people at least in this life wearing
jewelry
because of our fallen natures we have a
tendency to
you know lean towards vain things
and the children of israel when they
spoiled the egyptians and they took all
the jewels soon they made it into a
golden calf
god said break off your ornaments so i
can know what to do with you and pastor
ross might help me find that verse in
exodus i forget
um and god told jacob or jacob was going
to meet with the lord and he said
tell them to take off your jewelry and
they buried it and you often find during
times of revival you read in isaiah
chapter 3
it's that the daughters of israel have
become proud and they're prancing
wearing
and then he identifies all these
different jewels and things and
and some people are insecure about their
appearance or their value and they try
to increase it by uh you know
accessorizing uh and now we're living in
a day where
uh people's bodies are sort of becoming
a canvas where not only
tattoos that the bible says christians
should not do
uh but also you know it's not just a a
ring
or a wedding ring then it's you know
many rings on one finger and then as
many earrings in the ears and many
earrings nose rings and eye rings and
you start saying yeah would jesus do
that
so i i could understand that would be
tough my brother owned a jewelry store
he and i had different convictions but
um
he used to tease me a little bit too but
i
i would not be comfortable and you know
james says anything that is not of faith
is sin
i'd be starting to look for something
else to do
just because it seems like there's so
much vanity
connected with it all has to do with
like personal adornment and vanity and
i would be uncomfortable but you have to
have the holy spirit guide you in that
i'm making a matter of prayer charles i
think the fact that you're calling and
asking means
you've been thinking about this maybe
the holy spirit has
been convicting you somewhat and you
know i think pasadec they're just some
types
of of careers or businesses that
that christians should do their best to
avoid um not only
charles is asking about jewelry but what
about somebody who
sells alcohol to the public or tobacco
or something that we know the bible says
not good
at some point in time you begin to
wonder you know maybe maybe the lord is
leading me to sell something else
something
helpful or useful for society versus
something that can pull people down
yeah yeah so you know ask ask god to
open the doors and give you
some guidance and and i'm sure we'll now
we do have a book that talks about uh
jewelry i've got a book i wrote called
jewelry how much is too much
and we'll be able to send that to anyone
and it sounds like charles you've
studied the subject and you
might want to take a look at this book
again and or maybe share it to somebody
else
the number is 800-835-6747 and again the
book is called
jewelry how much is too much and we'll
be happy to send that to anyone who
calls and asks and
take a look at what the bible has to say
about personal adorning i think you'll
find that interesting
we've got steve listening in canada
steve welcome to the program
yes good evening pastors well i would
like to know the
heavenly sanctuary and by the way i'm
looking for the family sanctuary that
you're going to go
and sign up already uh 2nd of april
right
yes the amazing sanctuary program
yeah i'm looking forward to all that
thank you very much for everything you
share us because
you i i think you guys all and other
pastors too i'm not saying this to be
nice
try to save everybody so in the new
jerusalem we can all be there amen to
that
yes thank you very much so this is my
question since 1844 or
37 of october christ
is in the heavenly sanctuary if somebody
as much as
innocent as a child fate you know in all
his heart all his mind all his soul
in his character um can he feel that
presence of that special place in heb
inside of him so
does a person who is innocent feel the
the presence of christ interceding in
the sanctuary
is there something special well you know
i would think that for any believer
at any time in history
god has given us the opportunity to have
christ in us so abraham i think had a
relationship with god where he walked
with god
enoch walked with god uh you know i
think that
you know innocent people or people that
love purity of heart you know may have
more of an experience of that you know i
think if you parallel that with
the high priestly ministry of jesus in
the heavenly sanctuary you know that the
final phase of the work of jesus is a
high priest
we refer to that sometimes as the
cleansing of the sanctuary and we
recognize not only is there sanctuary in
heaven but
the church the individual the bible says
no you're not that your body is the
temple of the holy spirit there is a
work of cleansing and
right now christ is wanting to do a work
of cleansing in the hearts and the lives
of those who trust in him
and yes there is a drawing close to the
lord and there
is the peace and the joy that comes from
full surrender so
is this something we can experience
today absolutely that's what god wants
yeah so and we are very thankful that
you're planning to join us for the
amazing sanctuary program maybe pastor
ross you can tell a little bit about
what that is
absolutely it's coming on april the 2nd
it begins at 6 30 pacific time we're
going to be
live streaming this and also on the
amazing facts
television channel facebook and as well
as youtube channel
a special 13 actually 14 part series
focusing on the sanctuary and the
lessons that we can learn
all the way back from the hebrew
sanctuary that was in the wilderness all
the way to the heavenly sanctuary
where jesus ministers of the high priest
i think it will be a
really exciting weekend we have some
guest speakers past today that will be
coming in
a number of our evangelistic amazing
facts and partnering with some other
ministries so
uh make a note of that join us friday
april the 2nd it starts at 6 30 p.m
pacific time
and it's going to be live stream so hope
you'll take advantage of that
amen hey thank you steve for your
question and for giving a little shout
out for the amazing
sanctuary program we have uh juliana
listening from canada
juliana welcome to the program thank you
uh good evening pastor doug and
pastor ross yes thank you for calling
and your question tonight
yes my question is does the seventh day
adventist teach his
three resurrection my question is based
on
revelation 14 verse 13 where it says and
i heard a voice from heaven saying
unto me right blessed are the dead which
die in the lord from henceforth
and i was listening to a uh
adventist pastor on youtube that says
henceforth
uh takes into consideration those who
accepted the message from 1844
to the last person who will die just
before
christ comes and that would be
one of the three resurrections
so i want to know if
this is something that we teach
all right there are technically
there are three resurrections for some
you've got the resurrection when a
person dies
and they're resurrected for if they're
saved
they're resurrected and they don't die
the second death
and then you have um a person of course
the reason you see me kind of hesitating
a little bit you do have people like
lazarus
who jesus raised from the dead well he
got old he died again
but he's going to get raised again and
we assume he was saved and he'll be in
heaven
and then there's some people who are
going to be specially raised when christ
comes again
you know jesus tells us i think it's in
matthew 27 or
when the trial of christ is in matthew
26 where jesus tells caiaphas the high
priest
hereafter you will see the son of man
coming on the right hand of power
and then also in revelation it says that
he's come into the clouds and
they'll see every i'll see him and those
also who pierced him
and so some of the people involved in
the trial the execution of christ are
going to be raised
to see him coming as king of kings i
think the verse referring to matthew 26
64. that is jesus before the high priest
and he says
you've asked for proof that i'm the
messiah i'm paraphrasing this and says
you will see me coming so
revelation 1 7 says at the time of the
second coming there will be those who
will be
resurrected who pierced him so they
those who played a leading role in the
crucifixion of christ so there
we call that the special resurrection of
christ daniel 12
1 says some shall be resurrected to
eternal life some to shame
and it talks about this group of people
but then we have
the first resurrection the general the
big resurrection of the second coming
for the righteous
then there is a second resurrection that
occurs at the end of the 1000 years and
that's for the wicked
revelation 20 says blessed and holy is
he that is part of the first
resurrection
right so that's the resurrection of the
righteous so yeah
technically you can't probably say three
resurrections but
the special resurrection is just for a
small group yeah
generally speaking jesus said the hour
is coming i think this
is john chapter 5 the hour is coming in
which all that are in the graves will
hear his voice
they that have done good shall come
forth the resurrection of life
they that have done evil the
resurrection of damnation so you've got
two distinct resurrections one of life
that in christ rise first one of
damnation or condemnation according to
daniel 12
and that's the ones who are raised at
the end of the 1000 years according to
revelation 20.
now pastor ross we have a lesson that
talks about the millennium that kind of
touches on those resurrections yes
it's called a thousand years of peace
talks about the 1000 year period spoken
of in revelation chapter 20.
and as we mentioned we'll be able to
send this to anyone in north america the
number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can ask the study guide it's
called a thousand years of peace
it's all about revelation chapter 20.
next quarter that we have is ian
listening from michigan
ian welcome to the program hi pastor dog
hi pastor ross my question is in regards
to
the sabbath day the sabbath rest um
how about the seventh-day adventist
hospitals they have to operate 24 7 the
nurses the doctors the custodians
the cooks everyone who has to work uh um
how how do you relate to that in terms
of like the sabbath rest
yeah well there's nothing wrong jesus
healed people on the sabbath there's
certainly nothing wrong with that
and uh you know christians for
many many years have taken care of
people seven days a week
in hospitals and uh you know
whether christians believe the first day
is the sabbath or the seventh day is the
sabbath i don't know of any christian
hospital where the staff walks out and
says what's the sabbath i'm sorry you're
just gonna have to wait we'll see in 24
hours
so you know jesus said it's better to do
good on the sabbath day
and healing and caring for people well
you know
he said if your oxy or donkey fall on
the ditch you'll take care of them on
the sabbath
heavens why wouldn't you take care of a
human you know i think for those who
want to keep the sabbath and of course
the bible tells us to keep the sabbath
and you are in the healing profession
you're involved in in
working at a hospital you would want to
try and arrange your schedule
so that um even though you're taking
care of the needs of the people on the
sabbath
it would be good to at least have some
time off because we've got nurses in our
church and doctors and they try to
rotate through so
even though they do help on certain
sabbaths they like to also have some
time where they can go worship yeah swap
schedule so you're not
so it doesn't become a habit where you
miss church every week that's not good
either
all right thank you ian appreciate that
all right we've got uh let's see
robert is in washington college place
washington robert welcome to the program
hey i got to be squeezed in you did
and your question i was going to know if
you could explain
zechariah 12 1. all right let's look at
it real quick
and it says here the burden of the word
of the lord against israel
thus says the lord who stretches out the
heavens and lays the foundation of the
earth
and forms the spirit of man within him
now what is your question on this
in particular
well according to one religion anyway
that they said
that there's a ghost in a person and the
ghost
goes to heaven kind of thing want to die
the spirit right well
the word spirit here i could double
check but i'm pretty sure it's the
hebrew word roach
which means a breath and but that word
breath there
is you know it's kind of interchangeable
with
um let me see here
yeah the word breath here is
interchangeable with the word
uh the spirit of life that god gives his
creature like god breathed into adam the
spirit of life and he became a living
soul
yeah so that the word is roach and it
just means
okay yeah the spirit the agent of life
that god gives man i'm looking it up in
the hebrew right now
so um it's talking about the breath of
life that god gives man
and not only man pastor but all living
things receive that that breath of life
um so yeah it's it's the spark of life
that
only god can give so it's not
god forming a ghost it's god forming the
breath of life and the
whatever yeah well there's two words
that are being used here in zechariah 12
1. you'll notice the word
form and you'll notice the word spirit
and man
i guess that's three words you find
those same words in the creation of adam
it says god formed adam named a man
gave him the spirit it's basically
referring back to the creation of man
that god is the one who does this
and so god is the the real message in
this chapter
is what he says afterward he's beginning
by saying i've got a right to say what
i'm saying because i'm the one who makes
man
all right well thanks for the call
robert and hope that helps we have diane
in canada diane listening from british
columbia diane welcome to the program
hi there thank you both for taking the
call yes my question is
about revelation 4 6. it talks about
four beasts and i'm just wondering what
those
beasts are yeah you know that's a
it's a wonderful for keep in mind that
in revelation you've got a lot of
symbols so what you're really asking is
what do those
four beasts around the throne symbolize
and uh pastor ross has a good answer on
this
i might elaborate when he's done well
you know it is interesting of course
revelation is a symbolic book because
pasadena says and
if you look at the description that we
find in revelation chapter 4
about these four living creatures says
the first has the face likened to a lion
and in the bible a lion often represents
royalty or strength jesus referred to as
the lion or the tribe of judah
and then the second is likened to a calf
or an ox that was a beast of burden
the third is likened unto a man or has
the face likened unto a man
and then the fourth like a flying eagle
now as
various scholars have looked at this
they've noticed something interesting
they see the lion as perhaps
representing christ before coming to the
earth is preincarnation
the ox or the calf being a beast of
burden jesus came to bear our sins to
die in our place
the man would represent jesus now as a
high priest
he is still united with humanity
glorified but still united
and then the eagle would be connected
with judgment in the bible and eagle
sometimes refers to judgment talks about
an army coming swiftly as an
eagle interesting to note that one of
the emblems used by the romans
was an eagle of course an eagle is also
symbolized even in the united states
representing the nation
so the four phases of christ's ministry
are seen here in these four living
creatures
but really it represents um god's throne
it's as if these four living creatures
even make up his throne he has a living
throne
and that's this prophetic picture that
we see in revelation 4.
yeah that's good and you know one more
thing to remember whenever you read
revelation
it's springing out of the old testament
not only do you find this here in
revelation chapter four but if you go to
ezekiel chapter one
it talks about creatures around god's
throne as for the likeness of their
faces they are the faces each of a man
of the face of a lion each of the four
of the face of an ox
and the face of an eagle same four
creatures so it's not a coincidence
a and four in the bible represents
something universal
god sends his angels to the four corners
of the earth north south
east west and revelations um what is it
14 it says the angels are holding back
the four winds
and talking about something universal
and some have thought that
the four gospels really give a universal
picture of christ you've got
matthews kind of giving the picture of
jesus as the lion
mark is jesus is the eagle luke is jesus
luke's the physician jesus the man the
son of man
and then john jesus the sacrifice the
oxen
so it's just a wonderful very deep
picture
of the characteristics of god hey thank
you um
we got time for one or two more
questions all right we've got laura
listening in wyoming
laura welcome to the program hi
um i i've had this problem for a while
it's from matthew chapter 22 verse 14.
many are called the few were chosen and
this is where a king has
a wedding for his son and nobody wants
to come and so they
pull people from the street and and one
person comes in without wedding clothes
and i know that it's a parable and i
know that this wasn't a specific wedding
but um where do you get the clothes
i mean i i you know some people say well
clothes are given with the invitation
and everything but
if that were so then how come the guy
ended up without them
in the party yeah good question and
you need to be familiar with what the
customs were in the middle east with
weddings
now this is a king they used to assume
the responsibility for the
costs of a wedding and when the original
guests do not show up he tells the
servants look
you know bring in people from uh others
who will come in compel them to come in
finally they go out into the highways
and the hedges and the
the lame the poor everybody's brought
into the wedding but the king
would give a garment to everybody as a
gift
and that's why the king when he's
visiting the guests he sees one guest
who did not put on the garment that he
provided
and this is a symbol that jesus has
the robe of his righteousness to cover
our sins
and we can't make it to heaven without
the robe of christ righteousness
and so it's uh it's really a picture of
that and
yeah the lord wants everyone there
that's why he opened the wedding said
please come
so how did he get in without christ's
righteousness
well as you say it's a parable and
nobody's going to slip in around the
gates or they're not going to you know
get
by the angels and say i snuck in and so
the king is just basically saying a
person
who might try to come in without the
robe of righteousness
they just they don't pass muster i also
think that when it says
go to the highways and the byways invite
all these those that you find bring them
in
it really refers to the gospel going out
to the gentile world at first the gospel
was preached
primarily to the jews but then after the
stoning of stephen in 34
the gospel really went out to to the
gentile world and there were many who
said yes i'm a christian
when christianity was finally legalized
some 313 a.d
there were many who became christian
because uh for political means
it became the popular thing to do they
claimed to be christians but they were
lacking
in the wedding garment so they responded
to the invitation but they didn't
receive jesus they didn't put on his
righteousness
and in the parable you know they cast
out of the wedding guard away and he
asked them
and it says they're speechless they have
no answer because
there's no excuse for us not to have
that what righteousness that jesus
provides
freely and he's paid for all right well
thank you for your call laura
thanks for your patience laura we know
you were waiting a while i think we're
going to try
one more here real quick before we run
out of time we have harry listening in
uh florida harry welcome to the program
thank you how are you guys i'm doing
very good thank you for calling
okay my question is um where it says
that we should judge angels
yes uh what angel what angels and why
us yeah you know the bible talks about
that
um paul says do you not know that you
will judge
angels and i believe is that in second
corinthians
where he says that and then you also
read in
revelation during the 1000 years we live
and reign with christ
obviously we're not judging good angels
you can read in the book of jude
there's only one chapter in jude and it
said that
you know these fallen angels are kept in
everlasting chains of darkness awaiting
the judgment and so that judgment that
these angels are awaiting it's the lost
angels it followed lucifer in his
rebellion revelation 12 said that
satan was cast out and his angels with
him
so we're not deciding whether they're
saved or lost but we might be affirming
that their punishment is just and the
verse you referred is first corinthians
chapter six verse three
with kind of an interesting verse it
says do you not know that we shall judge
angels how much more things that pertain
to this life and it's talking about that
one thousand year
period in heaven in revelation chapter
20. so yes it's not
determining who's saved and lost that's
god's what god does but
i think during that time period the
redeemed will have the opportunity to
review the record
not only of humanity or human beings but
even of the angels
and looking at the choices that they
made so
that's the judging the angels yeah and
you can read in revelation 15
4 it says for all nations shall come and
worship before you for your
judgments have been manifest the
manifest means
revealed unveiled so we're not going to
be having evil angels go before us one
by one
go guilty innocent guilty innocent we're
not judging like that
we're basically going to ratify the
judgment of god that these creatures
that were not born they were created
and he intended for them to live forever
that god is just
in casting them into the lake of fire
and
which happens at the end of the 1000
years and you might want that lesson on
the 1000 years that we mentioned earlier
oscar
and or is it harry rather in sarasota
thank you so much
if we didn't get to your other calls
tonight please forgive us we see laura
and joe and lynn
and john and oscar waiting we just
ran out of time hey you know what today
is the 21st
of march i don't think i wished
everybody a happy spring yet that
started yesterday no it did
okay we got the flowers here in
california we'll hopefully get more rain
and don't forget to tune in to the
amazing sanctuary program that is coming
on april 2
that'll be followed by the 10 deadly
myths of christianity check it all out
at amazingfacts.org and while you're
there
please click donate keep us on the air
god bless friends
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible
even better than before bible answers
live
is produced by amazing facts
international a faith-based ministry
located in granite bay california
the bible tells us that salvation of
course emanates from god
so we need to know something about god
to rightly understand and embrace
salvation
yet in the church today there's a great
deal of confusion about the nature of
god
the bible says god is one god but is he
three persons
is jesus also eternal god because jesus
is the son of god does that mean there
was a time when he did not exist or he
was brought into existence
is the holy spirit a person or is he
just the
force and the energy that god uses to
communicate
you know i thought this was so important
i really felt led of the lord to write a
book on the subject
called exploring the trinity one god or
three
in this book we answer those very
important questions we talk about the
history of the holy spirit in the old
testament
as well as the history of the holy
spirit in the church and how it has been
much debated
this is something we really need to
understand because jesus said
eternal life comes from knowing god
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel
transformed into satan the archvillain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet
and the first humans witness the
temptation in evil
discover god's amazing plan to save his
children
this is a story that involves every life
on earth
every life
the cosmic conflict if god is good
if god is all-powerful if god is love
then what went wrong
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org